peu ralenti engourdis par ce froid par
ces accumulations de neige avec pourquoi
tu me regardes mois on chante la
marmotte
mais c'est ça qui est sorti aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui que ce qui l a pas vu son
ombre un nouvelle écosse ses cheminées
que des sam qui est dit que livre
l'hiver va finir bientôt
oui sauf qu'en ontario c'est wild thing
i ly qui disent que l'hiver va continuer
toujours des cheveux l'accord pour des
prédictions sont pas tellement moyenne
c'est pour ça tout ça pour dire que
l'hiver va encore durer au moins six
semaines c'est ça alors aujourd'hui le
thème de l'émission nous avons tous de
découvrir ensemble ceux qui sont
ailleurs dans le monde
vous allez sur votre est resté là
bougeait pas ou non on va vous présenter
la vidéo et mais spécialistes ici un
studio mais animateurs anne-marie vent
oui mais montgomery leonardo cheminots
vont tenter de deviner le sujet de
l'émission hockey parce que vous
marie-claude vous connaissez le sujet
comme on dit au québec sont organisés
que le gars des vues oui et des vues
c'est moi ça fait des vues alors voici
la vidéo numéro 1 de l'émission voici le
thème l'émission en des images qui
défilent rapidement depuis très attentif
pour découvrir le temps tous on joue
ensemble les conflits ya les analyses et
les conflits gars musclés avec les lois
de plus en plus confondant vraiment les
soleils
qui marche
l'environnement on va rejouer on rejoue
du début soyez attentif je vous donne la
réponse
voici la première image vous voyez
trempe mais qui à côté de trempe de
madame noir est le président noir nom
des palestiniens noire des beaux cheveux
noirs là la mer noire oui voilà la
politique mais sérieusement on va
s'intéresser aux taux mois aux mois de
l'histoire des noirs
c'est un événement qui a été lancée
d'abord aux etats-unis aujourd'hui
depuis 22 ans maintenant on souligne
d'affaires je voulais on va se promener
au pays aujourd'hui on va pas rester
qu'à montréal on voit aura pas cette
déformation professionnelle on leur a
pas jouent le jeu assure on va aller
d'abord vers ce qui se passe à toronto
êtes vous prêts oui alors c'est d'un
événement on va aller faire et vidéos
numéro deux c'est un événement qui aura
lieu dans quelques jours à toronto pour
souligner l'histoire démontré noir et
puis on le fait de belle façon les films
des films qu'il ya pas il ya pas un film
en français là dedans mais il ya
peut-être des choses que des roquettes
et je vous avais déjà vu comme ça aussi
on va regarder la bande annonce
moi si vous remarquez a fait ces choses
ludiques québec les noirs
[Musique]
il s'adresse à clessé non je sais pas
j'ai vu aucun de ses films
est-ce que vous avez vu certains de ses
films non
j'ai patiné félicite la table on est
tous des cinéphiles on n'a pas le temps
d'aller au cinéma
ça a l'air vachement intéressant oui oui
et
[Musique]
face à toronto et autre chose c'est la
capitale de non seulement des gens qui
viennent de sonde originaire de
l'amérique du sud et centrale c'est la
capitale c'est là où on est les plus
grandes populations plus grande
concentration
il ya le festival carabins
car il fallait s'est arrêtée puis les
c'est énorme aussi mondialement connue
ici à montréal va quand même parler de
montréal aujourd'hui on a une invitée
spéciale qui va nous parler d'une autre
activité qui a lieu en ce moment même à
montréal
voici notre invité je vous donne son nom
vous allez découvrir les allés poser des
questions d'accord c'est comme s'il y
avait un sujet mystère d'accord qui est
alors elle est joueuse il s'agit de
kerlande mibel bonjour madame bonjour
est ce que vous êtes dans votre salon
vous êtes au niveau de l'organisation de
l'événement la tapisserie derrière vous
vous même dire est ce que vous êtes dans
un lieu public connu à montréal
très connue très apprécié mes collègues
ici doivent deviner quelle équipe et
elle a le sourire là leur joyeuse la
danse à ce que c'est que ça est-ce que
vous organisez le festival de films à
penser montréal qu'il organise est-ce
que ça à faire avec le monde des
affaires
oui
voilà la roma et le monde des affaires
ce que vous vendez des produits non moi
je vais rebouger a réponse à tout pour
nous dévier de brie bella je suis tu je
suis très embêté parce que je me dis ok
c'est le monde des affaires mais c'est
le monde artistique aussi
pas du tout non rien d'artistique c'est
la culture est quand même oui c'est bon
est ce que c'est pour promouvoir les les
business noirs ici à montréal
l'entreprise
les entreprises du policier détective
oui mais des journalistes aux questions
à marie bell la ja ya en plus un lieu
connu
vous êtes au montréal international dans
ce cadre il à terre là du montréal
international
un peu plus haut
bon ça ça va aider nos auditeurs khalid
[Rires]
s'élabore la boîte en gnv quand même la
loi est trop peu l'événement c'est un
lieu qui a quand même lieu qui a
beaucoup aidé la construction de
montréal
vous êtes dans vieux montréal ouais vous
êtes dans le vieux bus dans le quartier
chinois
à l'hôtel de ville
oh on vous a perdu que vous êtes près de
l'hôtel de ville
on est prêt le père de ville vous êtes
au musée nempont musée descendre au
centre des sciences ce que vous qui se
tient en ce moment au sein des siens
mais là non oui il ya une belle
exposition sur les autochtones oui oui
oh oui là est ce qu'elle est terminée
j'espère que non mais c'est sûr non non
je pense passer sur les inventions
talent vous êtes vous êtes à la
l'exposition chez les autochtones les
géniaux tatane non j'ai été moi avec mes
neveux là l'exposition mais le monde des
affaires
oui la science et comme on écoute et on
va cesser de faire languir est en fait
savoir on est prêt vous êtes support
alors de quoi s'agit-il
en ce moment qu'est ce que vous faites
en ce moment actuellement nous sommes en
train de préparer la deuxième édition du
forum économique international des noirs
donc l'événement va avoir lieu demain et
dimanche donc samedi à dimanche le toit
et cap février et puis voilà deux jours
dans lequel on se réunit faut soi
apprendre à développer son projet
d'affaires à croire que son projet
d'affaires développé sa carrière pour
ceux qui veulent devenir des 6 août à
prendre à coder et apprendre à investir
et parallèlement à ça on a des gens qui
des entrepreneurs sociaux qui se
réunissent pour trouver des solutions
concrètes que les noirs faire mettre en
application pour pour faire face aux
enjeux économiques que nous vivrons puis
évidemment il ya toujours des
conférences du métro king tout ça pour
que ce soit toujours intéressant vous
attendez des gens importants je pense
que la nouvelle mairesse de montréal est
attendue oui donc participeront à
mairesse valérie plantes
la vice-première ministre ministre de
ligne de l'économie madame anglade
le ministre de l'immigration fédéral
également monsieur ahmed monsieur ahmed
hussein qui va venir
et puis on a pas mal de gens
d'entrepreneurs d'entrepreneurs des
communautés noires et d'hommes
d'affaires des communautés noires qui
évolue au canada et à l'étranger
également qu'ils vont venir à participer
à cet événement alors qu'est ce que ça
veut dire si par exemple je suis à
l'écouté en ce moment à montréal n'y a
pas beaucoup de gens qui sont l écoute
en ce moment nous souhaite en être bien
sûr mais si j'étais à montréal et que
j'étais se sentait visée par cette
activité est ce que par exemple je serai
une femme voulant lancer en affaires
j'ai besoin d'un petit peu des deux
conseils à ce que c'est là où je peux
aller où ça va être une excellente place
pour venir ce week-end parce que pendant
deux jours on a des entrepreneurs qui
ont réussi donc les côtes s'est passé
pas n'étaient pas des professeurs j'ai
rien contre les professeurs est en
profond même mais ça tombe bien mais
c'est des hommes et des femmes
d'affaires qui ont réussi qu'un chiffre
d'affaires dans leurs entreprises
croient qu'ils vont venir pour
accompagner is off c'est quoi les aubes
star donc ils ont vu ils ont développé
des stratégies pour contourner pour
faire face à ces obstacles à ces
obstacles là et c'est eux qui vont et
c'est eux qui vont venir coacher les
gens on off du coaching pour les
entrepreneurs du coaching pour des
professionnels qui veulent devenir des
cadres supérieurs
on offre également toute une
introduction au numérique donc comme
encoder apprendre à coder et puis
comment apprendre apprennent également à
investir dans qu'on a on a ça qui se
passe pendant ce week-end les autres aux
verts à tous à tous ceux qui ont voté
pour les communautés noires mais
vraiment finir d'accord pas voir des
noirs qui vont venir aussi donc j'en ai
yamaki moldavie qui vont venir donc
puis dans les autres activités que nous
faisons il ya des noirs qui participe
également et puis ça vit très bien la
vie est belle elle assure ne sont pas
exclues c'est bien c'est bien le
fantastique
bonne chance et fait souvent comme y'a
pas que les noirs peuvent poser toutes
leurs questions ils faire face à l'ordre
c'est vraiment est ce que vous donne ce
que nous on met à l'épreuve les
connaissances de nos collègues vous êtes
une collègue professeur à l'ens voici
l'accueil
dites-moi est-ce que vous avez une idée
du pourcentage de personnes qui sont ici
ce qu'ils se déclarent noir au canada
sont les pires ans recensement au canada
pourcentage mais je sais qu'on est un
peu plus d'un million de 1 million et
plus au canada
ouais ouais ouais on va vérifier ça je
pense que vous n'êtes pas loin de la
bonne réponse je vous donne un clin
d'oeil là mais c'est très visible à la
caméra merci écoutez madame carland
mibel bonne bonaventure belle aventure
et puis je suis sûr qu'on va envoyer une
équipe ou deux sur les lieux pour voir
comment ça se passe on a de vous voir à
bientôt
sympathique et puis en plus de ça nous
c'est super sympa d'avoir la personne
ici comme dans les téléséries star trek
à l'écran directement non jeu à la
technique la semaine prochaine je pense
qu'on va voir notre nouvelle invention
pour notre jeu relevez vous les méninges
parce qu'on a eu l'accord de la chef
technique ici je me dis oui vous pouvez
aller de l'avant monsieur parent et donc
ça fait j'ai l'autorisation depuis deux
semaines je posais le faire cette
semaine parce que avec un peu
d'électricité donc qu'il va faire sauter
un peu les partisans si on donne la
mauvaise réponse reçoit un choc
électrique
ceux qui ont la bonne réponse reçoivent
que petites tapes voilà voudrait la
question de la première question lui
vaut les ménages parce que juillet poser
mais je vais la modifier un peu parce
que j'avais entendu un peu plus d'un
million je passe semaines a calé
pourcentage est ce que moi si l'accès
question que je demande à quel
pourcentage de personnes qui
s'identifient comme noir au canada
moi je dirais plus avec claude droit
pour sa transmission à damas middle
pourquoi 3% à 38 ans c'est qu'en mai 33
millions 36 36 entre 36 et 38 je suis
moi c'est pourtant ce 1 7%
enfin oui mais lui un ordinateur
pourquoi vous faites pas la recherche
afin que bouchehr cela fait vous allez
voir si ce n'est pas parce que la pub
mac mark mark damon à tence 5 pour sa 5
pour ça
la bonne réponse anne-marie gelais
l'avez-vous non mais j'ai pas le temps
de chercher chez moi je suis pas ma pire
avec ces trucs là 12% 12% alors elle a
quatre fois éloigné de la bonne réponse
vous avez la patience en 3% à 2 9%
ce coupon palais les millions en quatre
ans et 36 millions de citoyens d'accord
alors c'est la plus forte proportion de
49% de la population qui s'identifie
comme étant noir au canada avec la ville
de huy et 22 % habitent la ville de
lorient
donc c'est une population
essentiellement métropolitaine si vous
l'aviez oui oui vous êtes d'accord parce
que je vous entends ça vaut pour 10 pour
20% l'examen cette semaine
il ya trois questions aujourd'hui à
l'examen au grand examen je m'inquiète
pas la dernière c'est à moi la dernière
c'est 50% alors puis raté les deux
premières salles au clair voici je
voulais vous vous présenter qu'est ce
que j'ai ici
ah oui il ya une plainte je pose une
petite question une plainte et a31 qui
était dirigé à la commission de
toponymie du québec concernant les noirs
ce que vous souvenir voix vous évoque
quelque chose concernant les noms de
noir toponymique la veille non péjoratif
qui existent au qui existent je pense ça
existe toujours au québec
sa peine est quelque chose puis ils
veulent changer ça parce que je sais
c'est pas des roses en français il y a
aussi le mot [ __ ] [ __ ] je le dis je
veux dire deux fois ici la mission alors
il y avait une planète et il y avait un
nom de ville ou de ruisseau de la qui
possède le mot dans cette dame qui était
une militante noire elle a eu gain de
cause
ça a pris un petit peu de temps il ya eu
négation de la part de la commission ne
peut pas changer c'est pas bon et
finalement ils ont changé d'idée ils ont
annoncé que tous les mots seraient rayés
de la carte
le problème c'est que le québec était la
seule province au pays il y avait encore
des monts avec ses moules ou de lieux
incroyables seuls endroits au pays où
c'est encore en vigueur
c'est des noms anglais ou français et de
langues dans les deux langues
on a préparé ce petit reportage pour
vous pour vous vous montrez l'opinion
les du coup les deux côtés de la
médaille blanc et noirs on écoute
non ça s'est passé pas la bonne vidéo
nos remarques le site web du forum
économique international des noirs vous
auriez eu la réponse si on l'avait
diffusée plus tôt c'est pour ça qu'on
l'a pas fait oui c'est toutes les
personnes importantes qui vont être
présents à cet événement et donc leur
site web peut laisser défiler parce que
ça nous a coûté un million d'arbres dire
ça ça coûte très cher la production
radio canada comme vous le savez indiqué
le syndicat et les patrons attendent est
prêt pour la prochaine vidéo où on parle
justement non les nombreux d'entre elles
sont en effet celles ci le baseband
jackie robinson ou encore le géographe
georges and ride ne sont que quelques
exemples des personnalités proposées
la commission de la toponymie du québec
c'est d'abord pour souligner leur
contribution puisque très souvent on ne
dit pas que le québec bien les débuts
donc dès sa fondation était déjà pluriel
l'éditeur du magazine 35 ans sic
explique 1 ça fait partie de la race in
man ça permet aux gens de se dire ici
c'est chez moi puisqu'il ya des gens qui
meurent exemple annuellement
et quand vous venez ça allait base dans
vous allez à new york vous retrouver
quand vous
les harley de vous retrouver facilement
le boulevard martin luther king
les brûleurs malcom x de tout ça ça
salling à peu près donc
c'est une appropriation pour dire nous
sommes dit si nos racines sont ici il ya
quelques communautés qui s'intéresse un
peu plus à cette situation la pomme les
italiens d'autres qui ont pu trouver
dans quelques quartiers ils ont pu
utiliser quelques noms mais dans la
majorité ça reste totalement redisons
canadiens français est encore bon la
commission plus sans tain et au départ
on voulait surtout faire en sorte que la
toponymie le fer français soient
conservés et par la suite de ça évolue
ça évolue avec les changements de la
société
le porte parole de la commission de la
toponymie du québec jean-pierre leblanc
se défend bien
il divo à faire une place plus grande
aux noirs mais aussi aux autochtones et
aux femmes et cela prendra plus de temps
c'est un travail de longue haleine ça se
fait à chaque année le fait d'en être
conscient de travailler à faire en sorte
que ces groupes soient reconnus dans la
toponymie la toponymie c'est un peu le
reflet de notre histoire
c'est un travail qui est assez long ça
se fait pas on veut pas le faire
tout d'un coup les noms ceux de l'ue
seront pas remplacés tous en même temps
donc on va y aller lentement et autant
que possible obtenir un consensus
ça prendra peut-être 100 ans alors je me
demande je pose la question est ce que
c'est vrai que ça prend beaucoup de
temps parce que souvient il n'ya pas
longtemps ils ont changé le nom d'une
petite parc vimy parc
ah oui oui oui pour deux parcs parisot
souligné monsieur jacques parizeau ça
n'a pas pris autant taxer non seulement
de la volonté tout ce qui est échangé
aussi assez assez rapidement ça se
changer le nom des stations métro aussi
ils ont ajouté des mots
alors je pense que ça peut être ça me
tire réponses mitigées alors c'était
monsieur jacques ça m'amusait d'entendre
le nom de famille de cet homme de la
commission de la toponymie monsieur
leblanc sympathique
alors écoutez ça plus amène parce que
quand les nouveaux une partie de la
communauté noire s'est plaint par
rapport à l'existence de certains
bouquinent devant payet
ils ont dit on vous propose donc une
liste de 50 noms de personnalités noires
donc on a entendu monsieur en glaoui
anglade en fait georges anglade c'est le
père de dominique anglade qui est la
vice première ministre du québec là qui
va être présentée briser la barrière de
couleurs et ça ici au canada à montréal
leonardo on vous fait passer la bande
annonce de la question tam-tam canada
cette semaine c'est sur facebook vous la
lisez paume pour le plaisir de tous si
votre ville dv rénommée une des rues en
l'honneur d'une personnalité noire d'ici
et d'ailleurs quel nom lui proportionnée
vous et pourquoi alors une réponse ici
d'un master ou d'une auditrice qui
s'appelle masque août à diallo et elle
propose une réponse rapide mais kaboul
sens là c'est donc avec un point
d'exclamation
grâce à lui les noix sont libres
aujourd'hui il a donné sa vie pour la
génération de l'homme noir d'aujourd'hui
est ce que vous auriez des suggestions
ici autour de la table on a parlé de
jackie robinson
moi si on posait la question c'est pas
évident il faut que je me creuse la tête
en disant mais oui mais qui pourrait
faire partie de cette liste à part des
pages par des gens là on vient sûrement
de la samare les gens à l'extérieur on
les connaît c'est important de penser
aux gens qui vivent au canada on nomme
dénudées rue à montréal ce serait bien
que ce soit des gens qui ont vécu notre
image
avez vous des suggestions marie josèphe
angélique oui qu'est ce qu'elle a fait
c'était une esclave et elle a vécu à
montréal dans les années 1700 et qu'elle
est en fait il ya eu le grand feu de
montréal à cette époque là et elle a été
accusée injustement et elle a été pendu
et brûlé par la suite c'était une
esclave qui venait du portugal mais elle
avait des origines africaines et en fait
tout de suite on l'a pointé elle est
devenue la coupable et on a beaucoup
entendu parler de marie josèphe
angélique mais jamais on a accepté de
dire qu'elle n'était pas là la coupable
de ce grand feu il n'y a rien qui a été
fait depuis pour excuser la méprise et
donc marie josèphe angélique voilà je
vote pour rayonnant avez-vous des sujets
me morice la boîte sani c'était un ami
un artiste céramiste qui faisaient des
masques africains
ses amis se régénère zaïre maintenant la
république démocratique du congo congo
très engagé à montréal avec les artistes
pour la paix en plus il souffrait de
polio tanguay ted avait dans sa chaise
roulante depuis tout petit puis elle est
partout hamon est revue connue en
afrique où ici leur est connu ici oui il
est décédé à 15 ans mais a été très
actif dans plusieurs mouvements amant ya
toujours de grands sourires avec sa
chaise roulante électrique alors très
inspirant ici à montréal ou au québec
peut-être pas mais il ya le monsieur qui
était sujet d'origine pour le fameux
roman de tanguy qui est qui et qui a
vécu longtemps ici en ontario mettons
donc il ya ici en ontario
non ici au canada en natale et aux
accords parce que c'est un américain qui
se sauver par dix parmi là qu'on appelle
la honte de grandry j700 quelque chose
quelque chose comme ça oui mais comme je
dis c'était lui l'inspiration pour sept
romans américains qui est super super
bien connu
ça résonne bien ça voulez-vous d'autres
suggestions
oui moi j'ai fait une découverte cette
semaine j'ai dû bien évasive asie c'est
parce que je me suis vont poser à le
mois à la question je vous lorsque vous
moi c'était pas compliqué je j'utilise
mes talents de rechercher ces chalets
sur le web en disant c'est quoi les
timbres à l'effigié je vous suggère des
gens qui ont déjà été présélectionné
d'accord oui j'en plus de chances de
l'emporter non sur une ruelle est
parfait donc on voit si deux
personnalités il y en a d'abord on va
voir cette semaine c'est depuis quelques
jours on peut acheter ça pour lui de
l'an 50 10 timbres poste à l'éffigie de
cette dame qui s'appelle links alexander
elle est devenue le madame voulez vous
revenir un peu en arrière vers à en
avoir
c'est la question du temps qu'hakim
complètement choc comme les 1818 1918
1975 est connu à toronto surtout là mais
elle est devenue une animatrice de radio
très très très connus femmes de la
télévision et dire quelques années donc
et on lui attribue d'ailleurs la
création du terme minorités visibles
elle a fait beaucoup de choses mais ça
c'est quelques-unes de ses réalisations
on a écrit un article à ce sujet avec
sofiane et c'est sur la page de tam-tam
canada bien sûr pour les détails
et puis cet homme là céline kane
alexander 1922 2012 soit il ya une autre
vie premier canadien noir à accéder à la
chambre des communes comme député c'est
en 1968 puis premier à être nommé
ministre fédéral en 1979 il est aussi
devenu lieutenant gouverneur en ontario
donc leur besoin prennent dans cette
province
ici et l'autre chose qui était très
important ça c'est surtout avec les
nouvelles d'aujourd'hui c'est un
politicien qui ne pas été impliqués dans
aucun scandale
bon pas de commentaires c'est très
glissant comme terrain c'est peut-être
le sujet de la semaine prochaine on
verra on vous rien vitreuil celui que
vous voyez là c'est tout ça c'est elle
c'est le cow boy le premier cowboys noir
de l'ouest canadien mais là c'est une
histoire que je retiens pour vous comme
ça dans un hors jeu ne dévoile que un
peu plus tard à l'émission à dakar on
voulait qu'on le fasse tout de suite non
objection d'abord voici notre deuxième
question remuez vous les ménages
êtes vous prêts elle a 20 % des gens à
l'examen vous n'avez way tous les autres
vous avez vous êtes en attente d'un
meilleur score précis rompre ainsi la
deuxième question qui vaut pour 30%
l'examen final
quand on est arrivés dans le pays le
tout premier noir quand est arrivé dans
notre pays le pilote de bâle ii navire
pilote d'avion da costa oui non oui 17
quelque chose de 7 80
m
alors qu'il a la bonne réponse donc on
leur donne automatiquement 20% mais vous
pouvez encore ajouté avait pour cent de
l'autre côté si vous avez la bonne date
où tous est plus proche de la date de la
bonne date 17 80 mille sept cent
soixante dix mille sept cent soixante
dix c'est bon ça 1101 1801 1820 1820 6 7
81 17 80 je ne sais pas besoin de tous
très moi je disais 17 dollars 81 et 1791
est tous très loin de la bonne réponse
ce n'est pas au xviie xviiie siècle vous
reprenez on va prendre
deuxièmement sentant plus plutôt qu'elle
savait à quoi ça sert pas plutôt moi ça
ne donnerait pas de cesse 1680 ça mais
c'est ça à la fois la messe et s'appelle
6 1 mais c'est certain car 1680 ben
c'est ça ma réponse c'est les deux
d'accord et je sais plus de pierce avait
me rappelle plus bel et bien je vais
dire 1655 55 1692 c'est triste pour vous
triste pour vous nous avez pas besoin
des points
la bonne réponse et 1605 vous aviez
acheté 1,5 degré c'était ça fait si
longtemps c'est vrai que ça fait
longtemps
arrivé dans les premiers bateaux là on a
mis du temps c'est beaucoup plus tard
que les que d'autres sont venus ni son
prénom c'est mathieu oui mathieu da
costa rica où on va regarder un peu ce à
sa vie oui en images grâce à notre
machine à remonter le temps
[Musique]
en question c'est très stylisé et plus
beau que cette image l'envoyer on peut
ajouter
donc il est repris par plusieurs
artistes qui ont été inspirés par cet
homme-là alors vos peintures chapeau
ouais alors on ya pas qu il n'y a pas de
photos de lui
ses origines sont sont en a fléchi et
wind assez parlé première interprète
d'origine africaine buts et j'espère
c'est tentant d'encadrer ne lisez pas
tous paraphraser quand même sinon j'ai
pas le temps de le dire avant là ok
attendait la première personne noirs
recensés à mettre pied au canada mme
mathieu da costa hommes libres embauché
en tant qu'interprète par l'explorateur
samuel de champlain dont 705 il était
déjà courant cette époque d'avoir
recours à des africains comme interprète
principalement le long des côtes de
l'afrique par le saint louis polyglotte
il parlait français néerlandais
portugais mais là c'est en fait déjà
trois fils d'izis devait y avoir des
langues africaines aussi j'imagine donc
il était très utile pour les contacts
avec les navigateurs et puis en fait
cette entente était de nature à lui
valoir une rémunération considérable
donc ils vivaient bien ce n'était pas un
esclave à cet important de savoir d'où
on en plus du gouvernement oui oui oui
il y en a qui disent bon certains
avancent qu'il aurait fait usage de
pidgin basque donc si une fusion entre
la langue basque et la langue leurs
câlins ou par led portugal espagne
aurait donc voilà et les basques du nord
de l'espagne s'était pas visiter
fréquemment les lieux de pêche répartis
le long de la côte atlantique canadienne
donc peut-être pas portugal mais espagne
bravo mais merci c'est par la
fantastique pour ses explications madame
le professeur
et voici maintenant une autre vous
préparer en question plus qu'on attend
d'un pull à combien de points celle là
on étudie ce que c'est la question des
mouettes
c'est là je pense que je vais attendre
car la chose est tout prêt pour le cow
boys en passant non mais comme le
premier cowboys noir de l'ouest canadien
oui ou lit alors en alberta ce soir je
peux vous rappeler c'est ça pour voir si
vous étiez attentive et j'ai l'histoire
ici non l'histoire
jean-louis un esclave 1 1845 dans l'état
de la caroline du sud dans une
plantation de coton et des états unis
john ware a grandi au texas et vers 1865
et le reiki sa liberté par la
proclamation d'émancipation après un
travail dans les fermes d'élevage texane
80 mai 1882 embauché par là pour
apporter mille états unis vers ce qui
allait devenir la province de l'alberta
je ne la connaissais pas cette histoire
et cdd dans les films nollywood j'espère
qu'il est parvenu à l'eva sûrement sa
cible j'avais remarqué aucune de nos
photos on était avec la neige ça va
falloir un peu noir un peu blanc et noir
a pas beaucoup de verdure
il avait des photos d'époque
[Musique]
bon même date est ici aujourd'hui
écoutez j'ai des choses sur l'escale un
gilet noir à montréal deux héros dc dans
la boîte de la radio canada un autre
terrain glissant
on peut pas comparer les deux choses je
vais faire mon patron je pense qu'on ne
peut pas comparer les deux choses
etes-vous prêts pauvres s'est bien
reprise de détresse où l'esclavagé y en
a eu un mot rien l'année au québec
ces histoires c'est sur la page de
tam-tam canada cette semaine des
dossiers découvrir avec des entrevues
notamment une qui a été réalisé par vous
en arrivant je pense je vais vous allez
voir disponible dès midi 11 minutes je
pense heure de montréal est toujours un
petit délai entre notre diffusion
officielle à 11 ans 11 et l'apparition
acquis du de la page web qui est la
coquille de cette émission mais en fait
en plus il ya un gros dossier ayant été
à radio canada international il ya le
gros dossier pour le mois de l'histoire
des noirs ya plein plein plein de
portraits c'est vraiment formidable à
découvrir ce qu'est un ce sujet de
marie-claude mais notre dossier a été
mise en ligne hier parce que le le mois
de l'histoire des noirs
ça commence le 1er février et puis déjà
plusieurs articles dans les cinq langues
de radio canada est en national anglais
français chinois arabe et espagnol il
n'y a pas que nous qui contribuait à
tous tous les réseaux radio canada en
france qui le fait c'est ça exactement
donc toutes les provinces c'est comme ça
depuis deux ou trois ans puisque ce ça
démarre maintenant début du mois mais
vous allez voir les textes qui vont
passer 2012 êtes vous prêts pour la
dernière question qui m'a donc un peu
comme sur aux olympiques on va
déterminer la médaille d'or ok parce que
ça sert à rien et la france se mettre au
goût du jour
c'est peut-être le sujet de notre
prochaine édition concoursde à parce que
toi des gagnants parce qu'il y est
lord l'argent et le bronze et on est
trois personnes donc on voulait tous les
trois dans d'autres là je sens que cela
que j'arrête au magasin dollars pour
aller chercher des médailles en bronze
avec des chocolats derrière pour la
semaine prochaine voulait revenir
attention la voici dans la question pour
la médaille d'or qu'elle rappelait - les
scores là pour le moment c'est 20% j'ai
90 non moi g20 vous avez 20
bonjour avoir dit s'il me restait le
restant là pour la dass et sans vous
aviez 30
c'est lui qui a dit la datex à lui ai
dit non non c'était c'était les noms
bobigny l'émission c'est pas plus
compliqué vraiment non mais elle devient
alors combien % des déchets on s'arrête
on prend des ont partagé par combien je
vais chaque étranger vous avez la
première réponse de 20%
il a eu la première partie de la
deuxième réponse était 20%
il a flanché à la deuxième partie c'est
elle qui a eu 30 % 5 1 pointe pour cette
keynote du score total quel est le nom
aujourd'hui d'une des dix provinces où
l'on retrouvait sur le territoire aux
18e et 19e siècles on couvre tous les
siècles émission ici la plus forte
concentration de personnes noires aucun
accord 50% 50% jeudi la première salle
est levé dès la première oui mais mais
elle est là elle entérine et avec
tellement d'enthousiasmé on a besoin des
bases et compris la semaine prochaine et
bazars aussi
on devrait 80% on n'a jamais un score
aussi élevé il s'agit d'un record du
monde
[Rires]
pour anne-marie allez hop
et puis c'est quand sédation pour vous
dénoncez bien quand même c'est 70%
c'est mieux que son score la semaine
dernière qu'ils étaient 60 pour soi j'ai
une question pour monsieur qui a inventé
les peler les quiz show les quiz show
c'était un américain qui s'appelle alex
trebek je vais dire la prochaine
émission mais c'est un canadien dans les
années 30 émission de radio est un
professeur d'école qui a eu l'idée
parce que dans son as dans sa classe il
y avait des gens qui écoutaient pas
c'est ça oui c'était le professeur
jacques michaud
dick we show reste des gauchos je
redonne à pons en complet la semaine
prochaine bah c'est fantastique vous
pouvez faire une vidéo en plus de ça
nous l'amener on présentera ses
documents historiques avec photographie
y avait pas de vidéo danse dans notre
jeu c'est très sympathique
alors le buzzer les médailles et puis
chocolat les électrochocs la semaine
prochain fantastique
alors je viens éjectable la semaine
prochaine on va parler des zones et
pékin parce que c'est politiquement
correct de le faire ou parce qu'on nous
oublie jeu fermé parce que je sais que
ce sera important de parler de la place
d'importance eux le canada seront
carrément sur ces jeux olympiques
nous n'avons que 36 millions d'habitants
et nous sommes dans généralement quoi en
troisième position dans ces jeux là au
niveau des médailles pour à peu près
ouais c'est quelque chose pourquoi
qu'est-ce qui ne passent que c'est
génétique oui probablement mais vous
faire aimer des jeux d'hiver oui il ya
des jeux
voilà tout s'explique
alors ma montgomery de la section
anglaise de radio-canada merci d'être
venu cette semaine c'est bon ça passe
par là la radio on a aussi une version
shannon non mais on à la télévision a
star davide bassi elle marie van rij
armes pinscher toujours lé d'espèces
autochtones
marie-claude si vous n'étiez pas là on
n'aurait pas eu grand-chose à des
missions aujourd'hui à main que coûte
simard merci beaucoup 6 et puis les eaux
gimeno c'était dont agréable de voir
aujourd'hui encore une fois merci
beaucoup à la semaine prochaine non
c'est non
[Rires]